hello and welcome to learning about it
with me lulu today we are going to be
learning about forks a fork is when a
piece attacks two or more pieces so the
game begins with E 4 e 5 pretty standard
white follows this with Knight f3
attacking blacks pawn on e5 Black Sun
plays knight c6 defending the pawn white
plays Bishop c4 putting his Bishop on
that nice open diagonal and also
attacking the f7 pawn black plays Knight
f6 attacking White's efore pawn white
plays Knight g5 again attacking the f7
pond and black plays h6 trying to kick
the night away but this is a blunder
because white can Forks black's pieces
by capturing the pawn on f7 forking the
Queen and the rook black can't take with
the King because the bishop is defending
the night so to recap today we learn
about forks a fork is when a piece is
attacking two or more pieces at the same
time often when the other player moves
one of the pieces that is attacked you
can still capture the other attack piece
thanks for learning about it with me
lulu